er ist kein glück und dann auch noch
pech das kann man wohl über die nächste
nachricht sagen eine fatale
kettenreaktion an heißluftballon ein
transporter mit anhänger und ein ex bnd
mann der am ende tot ist das war
passiert
ein heißluftballon wird zum verhängnis
tod durch zerquetschen am montag kommt
es zu einem schweren unfall in beelitz
ein mitarbeiter der ballon firma befüllt
vor der fahrt den ballon mit luft der
pilot ist schon an bord dann erfasst auf
meine starke windböe den ballon zerrt
ihn über den platz ein auto samt
anhänger wird mitgerissen ein
mitarbeiter hatte den ballon an dem
gespann festgebunden eine durchaus
übliche vorgehensweise der ballon soll
so stabilisiert werden doch auto und
anhänger werden mit solcher wucht vom
ballon mit sich gerissen dass die
tonnenschweren fahrzeuge zur seite
kippen und einen 69 jährigen fahrgast
unter sich begraben bei dem toten
handelt es sich um einen ex bnd
mitarbeiter weitere fahrgäste befanden
sich zum zeitpunkt des unglücks noch
nicht in unmittelbarer nähe mussten aber
von einem notfallseelsorger betreut
werden polizei und feuerwehr waren
schnell vor ort also das ballon
unternehmen arbeitet ja schon seit
vielen vielen jahren wir in der stadt da
ist noch nie was geschehen wie es
gestern zu diesem angekommen konnte wird
die polizei mit sicherlich ist schon
dramatisch ausgang der dort war die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt wegen
fahrlässiger tötung die überreste des
heißluftballons werden von der polizei
gesichert der tatort ist abgesperrt der
ballonfahrt anbieter ist bislang nicht
erreichbar ein anrufbeantworter
informiert darüber dass vereinbarte
ballonfahrten aufgrund von internen
ereignissen abgesagt seien pedro dix
anwohner am unglücksort und ehemaliger
hubschrauberpilot kennt solche
situationen vielleicht eine verkettung
von unglücklichen umständen
dazu geführt hat dass
eine windböe aufgekommen ist was auch
immer
die kräfte reichen schon aus um ein
fahrzeug mit sich zu reißen oder wie
gesagt auch der ballonkorb das sehr
schwer von ihm selber heißluftballon
fahrten sehen romantisch aus doch der
schein trügt leichtfertige flugmanöver
zu schnelle richtungswechsel und
gefährliche start und landung phasen
immer wieder kommt es zu unfällen in
beelitz kostete er ein solcher ausflug
und ein menschenleben
fragen wir noch mal nach bei kevin
scheinpflug er ist der ballon experte
herrscht ein flug aus ihrer sicht wie
konnte es zu diesem unglück kommen
nun ja grundsätzlich muss ich mich mal
vor sprecher anschließend wird es eine
verkettung negativer ereignisse gewesen
sein unheimliche windlasten die auf die
ballonhülle gedrückt haben werden
letztendlich dazu geführt haben dass der
ballon sich unkontrolliert in bewegung
gesetzt hat und dann dramatischer weise
in den bäumen gelandet ist inklusive
fahrzeug aber was sehr unüblich ist das
wirklich so enorme kräfte wirken es kann
mal passieren dass das auto sich ein
stück mit in bewegung setzt aber das ist
letztendlich umkippt und sogar meterweit
sich in bewegung setzt ist wirklich sehr
sehr dramatisch und absolut unüblich
also es ist aber eigentlich üblich dass
man das den ballon an einem auto
einfache befestigt oder ist das
fahrlässig ganz genau das ist absolut
nicht fahrlässig das ist völlig normal
sicherheitstechnisch wird der ballon
fixiert der korb mittel mit einem seil
am fahrzeug weil sie müssen sich
vorstellen der ballon liegt ja am anfang
wird mittels ventilatoren mit kalter
luft befüllt und sollte daher schon eine
windlast auf die hülle drücken würde wär
sicher und kontrolliert in bewegung
setzen das seil dient dann letztendlich
dazu den ballon zu sichern und wenn dann
eingeheizt wird kommt der ballon in die
senkrechte meines stopp bereit und kann
eine schöne ballonfahrt durchführen und
dementsprechend ist das völlig normal
vom ablauf her gewesen ja schöne
ballonfahrt sagen sie immer wieder gibt
es aber auch berichte des ballon körper
in bäumen lernen oder bei der landung
umkippen welche phasen der ballon
fahrerei sind am gefährlichsten
also grundsätzlich wie allgemein in der
fliegerei die start und landephase kann
man ganz klar so sagen
wie funktioniert eine reibungslose start
und landung phase
erst einmal muss man natürlich die
witterung beachten ist alles im
gesetzlichen rahmen so dass man ganz
normal ohne risiko die ballon aufrüsten
kann insbesondere die
windverhältnisse und
auch bei der landung kann es immer
passieren dass eine böe sozusagen den
ballon erfassen kann
das lässt sich leider nie so richtig
ausschließen aber bei denen anzahl der
fahrten durchgeführt werden passiert
wirklich sehr sehr selten west muss man
natürlich tatsächlich auch dazu sagen
kevin scheinpflug vielen dank für die
erklärung vielen dank
[Musik]